the
topic that we're beginning with is
really a passage in discourses 117.
epictetus says tu testing pro racine
prioresis in the context of
explaining how
a person determines their decisions and
actions and so what we're looking at
here is is a very important faculty and
then how it actually
works and it's pro-racist itself that
determines or compels depending on how
you want to render the passage
pararasis and so we're you know when
this conference was proposed i talked to
harold and i was like well should we do
a presentation
on maybe this and he said yes yeah
that's a great idea because this is such
a rich passage
in implications
and associations and this is an
opportunity for the two of us who
collaborate
on quite a few things we meet weekly
not only to talk about stoicism today
but all these other
projects within you could say the
philosophy of action and ethics and
things along those lines mostly in
ancient philosophy it's an opportunity
for us to
think about a larger set of topics that
we're interested in specifically pro
eraseus
and the
the notion of the will going through
ancient philosophy
into the early middle ages and that
involves a number of other closely
connected topics like
freedom and responsibility how we shape
our character
how decisions actually lead to actions
what you know what goes into that how
how that operates
and epictetus is very interesting in
that respect i i think
so some of the material and the points
that we're presenting here
it's it's a
we're cannibalizing a previous
presentation that we made
um which had a larger scope at the
aristotle and aristotelian tradition
conference this last summer
at marquette university there we were
discussing pro-eurasis and the epheme
in in aristotle epictetus alexander
vaphredesius and simplicius so
stoic and aristotelian traditions
um
i we also drew upon another uh
presentation that i made in the midwest
seminar in ancient and medieval
philosophy
some years back on epictetus and
priorasis and so
we're going to be discussing a number of
different aspects bearing on prairie
races and epictetus's works and thought
and stoic philosophy but
ultimately it's centering on one main
goal a better understanding of what this
passage means and implies because we
think that there's a lot going on
packed in there
and so
i'm going to give an overview and then
i'm going to hand things off to harold
and we're going to go back and forth and
this will be much more like a
conversation than
than a strict presentation
so we'll do a short history of the term
projects up to epictetus and then we'll
approach a always controversial topic is
epictetus an original thinker
is he a
derivative very orthodox thinker is he
somewhere in between
the scholarship is kind of all over the
map on that
and then we'll have a short discussion
of translations of the term
and that might actually be a good place
to open up
some discussion
or perhaps we'll we'll save that for for
later
um because you know we're looking
primarily at english but also at latin
but it would be interesting to have some
other
languages represented and then we're
going to consider some other relevant
passages about pro-racism its scope its
freedom its value
we're going to look at what pro-racist
is as a faculty or the core of the
person and there's a lot of literature
out there about that we're only we're
only dealing with a little bit of it
here in the presentation because
otherwise it could be you know an entire
day of summarizing the literature that's
that's currently available but there's
there's some interesting things and one
of the questions that we do want to
consider
in this literature is well is the
pro-erasis
is it the same thing as the hegemony
cone
is it different from it is it's
overlapping as some people have
suggested and how does it connect with
the
rational faculty
and then we're going to we're still
circling around the topic we're going to
talk about some key ideas and
distinctions that prairie racist is
connected with like the epimen
ascent
and then we'll get to the actual uh
topic uh looking at epictetus model
about how pro-racist determines is
determined or shaped or structured
one of the key aspects that we want to
spend a good bit of time discussing is
how prior racist is reflexive that is it
works upon itself as we see in this this
passage
what kind of modalities does this have
how does this how does this work how
does pro-erasis
compel or determine itself and we can we
can ask this in two ways how does it
determine itself
well
right rationally prudently
maintaining itself in the right way and
then how does prairie racist mess itself
up
you know
all of us have pro-races
that are
not in perfect condition you know if we
accept epictetus as model we're all uh
pro cop toy we're
we're making progress we're not sages
so how did our prayer races get so
screwed up in the first place and how do
they keep screwing themselves up that's
a good question and then if we have time
we'll we'll go into the the question
another one that harold and i are
grappling with quite a lot is prior
racist effectively what we call the will
a locus of freedom in stoic
compatibilism so um harold will take
over at this point we'll be going back
and forth and and sometimes we you know
harold you should feel free to interject
at any time that i'm talking and uh i i
will exercise the same liberty
thank you and please do
uh so prohibitis is not particularly
common term
uh and it's a term that seems to be used
in a variety of ways
centering on conception of choice
priorities and prioritization uh and
perhaps uh some deliberation
uh the term is used by retorts and
orators uh or readers and orders uh
like uh demosthenes and ice socrates
uh
and uh the muslim is used in the
expression uh prohibitors is to be you
um choice away or life four times in
various speeches
uh
term gets used
in verbal form
by uh great um
by uh different characters speechwriters
like uh ischemists hipperedus and lysias
it's used in verbal form by plato too
particularly the laws in the sophist
statesman syllabus and there's one
substantive use
uh
in the permanentes in 143c
uh
when he moves to when we move to arizona
the term gets used a lot uh especially
in the ethical and political works
both in
its use in the ethics in the politics
rhetoric and poetics and there the focus
is on deliberation
virtue and vice choice
and whether we are responsible for our
own moral character
uh
it also get used in on soul
physics metaphysics
uh and the focus there is on
the philosophy action and courses
uh
even gets defined by aristotle uh in
such a way that turns out not to work
well for all the contexts in which he
introduces or uses the term
uh
so it's a complex underdetermined and
very important idea
um
which can be a transit that's either
effectively imbued intellect or
intellectually oriented effectivity
uh
after arizona we see the term
prohibition is getting used occasionally
uh it's referenced in the magna moralia
uh
and their paris is between things that
can be done it concerns the kind of
circumstances in which it is up to us to
act or not to act
and to act in this way or not
and in which one can grasp the reason
why
that's in 1189 b6 through 25.
uh
philo of alexandria uses prohibited
students denotes something like
intention or commitment
and the historian theodore secular in
biblioteca historica
uses prohibisis in quite a few places
typically in terms of commitment or
character
uh the middle plateau is plutarch uh
who was contemporary epictetus uses
prohibits occasionally in both the lives
and various small treaties
and meaning there is
in choosing the path towards virtue
or in terms of committed choice in
politics
um
and we in cicero we have voluntars
voluntary
um
as well as in lucretius and seneca among
others
so if you turn to
use in
the stoics prior to epictetus
it seems like it
wasn't a particularly important concept
for them
uh inwood wright uh writes that uh the
old stoic use of this term diverges from
its aries and healing counterpart more
than any other
this is clearly an unimportant term for
the old store
later in
uh
in survivors
we find the definition of prohibitis as
a choice before a choice
we don't see any use of it in sony's
rufus
it is not a term that says zero notes as
being
used and in need of having a latin
translation or equivalent
we also don't see any use within
heroclies
and
we only see it a few times in marcus
aurelius
so it seems like it
started and died with epictetus at least
um
uh for the stoics among the thriving
sources
it's a tendency among many interpreters
to view epictetus as following along
with and transmitting stoic orthodoxy
which probably is the case in many
respects
but we also see a petite is seemingly
incorporating and innovating when it
comes to key ideas with stoicism
there is less emphasis on the virtues
he introduces the three disciplines
which we'll hear about more tomorrow
um
he has a focus on the distinction
between what is
what is ethamine
and
in our control in national control
uh
or up to us not up to us
as well as
concepts like prolapses
um and the topic of today prohibisis
in epictetus we also find a
reinterpretation
of the key stoic idea of living in
accordance with nature
as
maintaining prohibitions in accordance
with nature
prohibits this is a term that prior to
epictetus seems largely
to have been used in any robust manner
by arthritis and by later neoplatonists
who are assimilating arizona and
epictetus into a platonic framework
and i'll now pass it back to greg for
the
topical translation yeah so there's
there's a incredibly wide range of
translations in english not just of
uh pro-racist is used by epictetus but
also by these other authors like
aristotle
plutarch alexander of aphrodisias and
authors all the way down to simplicius
who who writes a commentary on
epictetuses and caridian which is very
very interesting because it's a
neoplatonous commentary
where he's um you know helpfully
explaining some things but but it's
clearly within a
a different framework and the literature
that's out there
you know the way in which these terms
are translated is just all over the map
and some people seem to have given a
great amount of thought to it others
seem to have picked whatever term was
was handiest and just you know hope for
the best and i think it produces a lot
of confusion
for people who can't simply go back to
the the greek
and
there's another point to note as well
because we're not just like looking at
the present or the near presence of
let's say the last 200 years of
scholarship and translation
this is a term that has a life in the
ancient period
in the west that you know the two main
important languages being greek and
latin
and
so
harold mentioned you know volontas
and the you know voluntary or how you
know whatever other um
cognates we we've got
sometimes this is used to translate
other terms like thelema you know the
the will of of uh fate or the will of
the gods that that's right there in
epictetus as well
or um
[Applause]
boule
or abuelasis
blasis for the stoics is a type of
rational desire
but it has a different function for
aristotle right and so these terms are
kind of loosey-goosey to use
a very suggestive term and we see this
in in like from seneca down to augustine
the the trouble is is that volunta seems
to be the closest thing to epictetus is
prior racist that we find
in the literature but it's pretty rare
that pro-racist actually gets translated
by voluntas
in medieval latin once the translations
of aristotle get made
it's uh kind of implausible like if you
read thomas's commentary on a nick of
mccann ethics
um
you look at the the latin text and then
um what thomas makes of it it's bulasis
that gets translated as voluntas and and
you you look at what bullasis is in
aristotle and you're like well that
can't possibly cover the same ground as
it it really should have been
um prior racist but pro-racist gets
translated
as arbitrium which is like a modality of
volontas and oftentimes as librium
arbitrium free free choice of the will
now we we actually looked at some latin
translations from the renaissance and
later of epictetus and caridian to see
how was pro-racist actually rendered and
we didn't we didn't you know survey all
of them but two of the very early
translations
it's interesting to see the terms that
are being used so in the nikola
parotti translation
this is looking at uh
encoding four you know where the first
uh
real focus on prayer races you know make
sure you don't mess up your prior races
when you go to you take a bath
it runs like this volo equidim lavari i
want to take a bath
said alexionum mam secundum ayus not
totem say hubentum to erie so priorasis
is being translated as alexio which is
clearly a word of choice right but maybe
doesn't have the full range that we we
typically associated with it in
uh epictetus and then in the angelo
politano translation
lavare volo i want to wash myself right
proposition
mayhem quotes
sir to main survivor to maintain
propositum
usually translated as like my intention
my plan what it is that i put before me
that it's capturing the deliberative
aspect a little bit better but again not
not uh closely connecting it in the much
looser
edward ivey and later translation which
is very periphrastic um there isn't any
word that corresponds to
um poreorasis instead he talks about uh
defenders so to maintain partus fortis
etengenui
so
you know it's a whole pic it's like a
whole set of words that are translating
it and you would never guess that this
is actually proliasis
if we look at english term english
translations of aristotle's term prior
racist which is a narrower concept than
epictetus is choice is a very common
translation often qualified by
other terms like deliberate or moral or
preferential or purposive
intention is another one i i kind of
like that purpose decision harald and i
have often used commitment as a good way
to translate aristotelian pararasis
one that's clearly wrong that erwin
proposes is will
so
you know there is if if anybody's prior
racist is will it's going to be
epictetus is not not aristotle's um what
about epictetus so
here we have a wider range because
epictetus treats priorasis as a faculty
or phenomenon of much broader scope so
we see this is just a this is not a
comprehensive list but faculty of choice
power of choice moral purpose
disposition that's from bob zian's book
uh
long likes the word volition for all of
the
seeming dangers of of you know giving
the wrong idea he's he's cool with that
long also uh uses the cell for moral
character
inwood talks about moral personality
which i kind of like
freda uh at one point in a free will
translates pro-racist as will
that's a little dicey but we'll talk
about why
and we can ask what does this range of
translations tell us
um and this is something that that
harold and i as well i mean harold is a
translator i i also
have translated in the past this is
something i think we're very
attuned to
the possibilities of misleading people
by choosing the wrong term you know
and we don't want this to become just a
conversation about
translation and and terminology but i
think this is a really important point i
mean harold what do you do you want to
weigh in here on on this a bit more
yeah i think that uh what we need to do
when we translate epictetus is that we
must simply give up the pursuit for a
perfect bird to translate it i think we
need to rely on a glossary uh and it's
not just for viruses either uh if you
take a concept like eudaimonia
or or even uh audi afore uh in different
things yeah i mean if you just stress it
as uh well those things that doesn't
make a difference
uh then that's not going to be very
helpful unless you sort of explain
the stoic idea that virtue is sufficient
for happiness and
yeah other things aren't on the same
level of goodness
on a similar note i think prolapses is a
term that's very difficult to
find a good english rendering for
that doesn't mislead you know
so so maybe you're right maybe maybe
having a glossary and indicating at the
start that people
ought to go to the glossary and look
around in there maybe that's our our
strategy
you know yeah yeah and a very good
introduction i think
uh and then
i think that uh
well
at least if we're going to do a new
translation in
english then you can just try to pick
the
least bad amongst the ones that have
been used so far
uh in the region it's a bit more
difficult since well at least the
discourses haven't been translated yet
so
so that actually it presents you with an
opportunity but also a greater
responsibility right
yeah i mean i can try to base it on
some translations of the ingredient
which has been translated a bunch of
times so
yeah
yeah i think that
the latest that i saw was um
the ability to choose
um
yeah what's translation for irises
okay
so now we're going to consider some some
relevant passages about prairie races
and its scope and freedom and value so
the larger context of the
um discourses 1 17 passage runs more or
less like this this is the hearts
translation
and i i instead of using hard's
rendering i've just put pro erasers in
there you have a prorasis which is
secure by nature from hindrance and
compulsion i'll demonstrate to that
demonstrate that to you first of all in
the sphere of ascent can anyone prevent
you from assenting to the truth no one
at all can anyone constrain you to
accept what is false no one at all do
you see that in this area you have a
pro-erasis that is immune from hindrance
constraint and obstruction
well then are things any different in
the sphere of desire and motivation
what can overcome a motive other than
another motive and that alone
what can overpower a desire or aversion
except another desire or aversion
so once again it is your judgment that
has constrained you or in other words
your pro-irasis has constrained or
determined itself and this is a very
rich
passage because what we see here two
things
is
you know pro-racist is moving both in
the the realm of desire motivation all
these affective things but it's also
cognitive it's moving with he's saying
you know you have a prayer racist that's
secure by nature from hindrance and
compulsion let's talk about ascent and
there's an interesting um
in some of the scholars there's a
tendency to say
what the earlier stoics were meaning by
this vast field of ascent is part of
what epictetus is calling pro-erasus
so that's important and then we also see
that prioresis works in part by taking
our present thing and then replacing it
with something else
so this is one way pro-racist actually
works upon itself
what can overpower a desire well another
desire and what decides what that desire
is going to be
as that does that right so this is a a
means by which priorisis
modifies itself
um
there's a couple other key themes that
we see coming up and we could actually
find you know we could talk about many
other passages so we just picked some
representative ones prairie racist is
the core
of what a person is
in in uh
book four he says you are pro-racist so
that's a pretty strong equation right
and then there's a couple other nice
ones you're not flesh nor hair but pray
racist so if you get that beautiful
you'll be beautiful
uh later a little later he says not
flesh or bones or sinews but that which
uses them governs and understands
appearances
so you know the our pro-racist is in a
way you you almost can't say our prior
racist you are your pro-racist you you
are that pro-racist right
it it's also the ethical locus good and
evil he says lie in prior races
um outside of prairie racist there's
nothing either good or bad this this can
be sometimes taken too far because
obviously
you don't want to go the mistaken route
of saying oh well then nothing matters
to me outside of my own little inner
citadel
it's better to say outside of pro races
nothing is good or bad intrinsically for
you
but you know what happens to your
neighbor is
still good or bad right how you treat
them is still good or bad
um choices or prioritizations that have
to be made we see a lot of examples
where epictetus says listen you gotta
pick a or b
and
interestingly
b will be keeping prior racism in
accordance with nature which is kind of
a higher thing
than whatever
temptation you have right now so if we
take the the bath house thing from and
caridian four you can get ticked off
about people stealing your towel or
making noise or stuff like that or you
can keep your priorities in accordance
with nature and you can't have both
so you use your prior racists to decide
which of these you're going to
maintain and then the last really
important theme
pray racist is free
radically free
he tells us that nobody is a master over
another's prayer races in uh
book four chapter 12. uh early on in the
discourses in uh book one
not even zeus can handle hinder my
prayer races right zeus gave it to me
but he he can't
um
change it and then in in 319 he says
nothing outside of the sphere of prairie
races can hamper or injure prior races
it alone
can hamper injure itself so when we
blame you know our bad condition on oh
you know i came from a culture that gave
me the wrong ideas oh it's the media or
you know my parents who were mean to me
or my teachers or whoever
epictetus you know he i think he'd be
willing to say
okay those are all you know what the
stoics might call um
auxiliary causes but the real cause of
you being screwed up is you
and you're you're prior races and your
choices that you made and you may have
been in situations where
unfortunately it was it was hard for you
to see you know like what the right
thing was and you got a lot of bad
messages that are all appearances
essentially but you know you're
it's still you and and this is very
optimistic in a way
because if if we can be
screwed up because that we can also fix
ourselves right
so there's a good transition to talking
about some of the
scholarly literature and i turn this
over to harold unless you unless you
want to say something about any of these
passages
uh yeah uh on the last point uh and i
think i'll get into it a bit later
but uh and that transitions into the
next section actually uh but uh zurobje
uh mentions the discussion he had with
michael frieda where he said that well
viruses is free
uh in one sense but it might also be the
case that you need to make it free i
mean if you have already compelled your
prohibitions then you need to do some
work in order to make it in the free
condition again
you know and this so this is a little
bit outside of the scope of what we were
talking about but this is something that
you and i have have discussed at a
number of points
um
i think that's right and i think that
we
in in traditional virtue ethics when
we're thinking about freedom and moving
towards the good and stuff like that
whatever faculty we want to conceive of
it as you know whether pro-racist or the
will or or something else
we use that to unscrew itself up
to make it
better to put it in better condition
gradually cumulatively through a process
that usually others have charted out for
us and then we we follow but we have to
understand experientially
and so what that implies is we can
build freedom
you know
and i think that's that's again a rather
optimistic uh side to it that often gets
left out for for people they want to say
either you're free or you're not it's
like an on off switch rather
you know and we could say that another
alternative is we could see it like a
continuum but in both of those are
actually kind of wrong when it comes to
prior races or the rational faculty it's
more like building a muscle
you know you uh have to do that over
time you do it through going into
difficult situations you stress the
muscle it it increases its strength and
mobility and uh its capacity to work
except in this case it's not a perfect
uh analogy because the muscle doesn't
move itself right the brain moves the
muscle
yeah and perhaps another uh similarity
with muscle is that if you're not uh
well in good shape and you try to
deadlift 300 kilos
then you might end up breaking your back
so or destroying the muscle yeah
yeah yeah that's a good point
um
does that does that translate well to
pro-racists i mean
there are some examples of people in
epictetus discourses who have really
really screwed up pro-races like the guy
who wants to hang out with him and he
says listen buddy you're an adulterer
nobody can trust you you you've taken
the man inside of you
the man of um
trust or faith right and you've
destroyed him
so that kind of implies that you could
you could damage your your prior races
pretty significantly
yeah and
i don't remember any specific place
replicated says that you need to be
careful about what kind of challenges
you introduce yourself to um
but uh i think it says at some point but
it kind of makes sense i mean
uh let's say that you become convinced
that virtually is the only thing that's
really good uh yeah you're a fresh
student of stoicism then
maybe you shouldn't try to
get tortured to death
or i mean you should probably avoid that
anyways but i mean you maybe it makes
sense to try to
be a bit careful about
getting into a really um
challenging situation yeah again this
takes us a little outside of the scope
of it but john cassian
and i i do think the monastic fathers
did incorporate a lot of stoic stuff
into their their discipline not not just
through uh of agrius ponticus you know
who is clearly influenced by
stoicism cassian advises people
to work on only one vice at a time
and he says that if you try to take on
too much you're guaranteed to fail you
know and i think that's actually really
good advice you know
yeah
and uh it also perhaps ties into into
the role ethics i mean when he talks
about the different um
and uh making choices in accordance with
your role yeah
and
now again something that we hadn't
really thought of maybe you know when
you talk about prayer races one of its
functions is prioritizing
and if you think about epictetus's role
ethics you have
every single
role that you have he says
signifies a set of duties that you have
or appropriate actions
how do you prioritize between them so
how if you're going to be a good
son and a good brother and a good
neighbor and a good citizen
you know sometimes one of those has to
give and so how do you how do you
determine that it's prior racist that
that settles that
right
yeah yeah that makes sense
so uh okay should we enjoy the next
section yeah
uh
all right so
uh
we're not going to go to a section where
i try to draw on some of the scholarly
discussions of other people and we're
going to try to
uh tackle four issues
uh the first one is
understanding what prohibitors is for
epictetus and the second is
what is the scope
of viruses what does it extend to
the third issue
is um is prohibited the same as
hegemonicon the rational faculty
the fourth issue
the rational part leading part
uh the fourth issue
is what comes to be called voluntas or
the will
and these issues tend to be blended
together
in discussions
so
if you turn to the first of the two
uh
tony long writes that this faculty
let us call it prohibisis for short
it's
the essential self as the fictitious
conceives of this the bearer of personal
identity
um um in um discovering the will right
paris is presented not only as the site
decisive factor in practical existence
but as the true self the inner man the
eye of personal identity
inward in ethics and human action in
early stoicism writes
he epictetus has elevated the term to
stand for a man's entire free power of
choice
which constitutes a small program for
life
and long again writes in its uh
monography and epictetus
volition or privacy is what persons are
in terms of their mental faculties
consciousness character judgment goals
and desires
what epictetus includes on this term is
each person's individual self with a
capacity of reason desire intention
reflexive consciousness
so we just to break in we can see that
within the scholarship of people that
are really you know digging into this
and thinking about this uh
quite quite long and hard people that
harl and i are taking as um
you know guiding lights
prairie racist is both the core of the
person and it covers a lot of stuff you
know it you whether we think of it it's
not identical with all of these things
but it runs the show you could say
it does
and um
maybe it's a good place to introduce um
swarovski's take i mean yeah
occasionally
uh
talks in the sense where it makes sense
to read him as saying that um
as the seneca by the way from time to
time in the first letter uh make
yourself free for yourself uh
so
do you think that there are
multiple cells there or is it more like
that's a good question i mean
it depends on
you like there's a true self that that's
like you know at the very core or
something and we we uncover it or free
it up
i don't know i i'm i
i think that
and again i don't i don't have this
really well articulated or
provided with all sorts of textual
evidence but i i kind of think that
prayer races um is like the rational
faculty in that there's no one locus of
prairie races there's no nugget of it
like you know a
thing that would always remain exactly
the same
something like you know substance or
lucia i think prior racists
like everything else for the stoics is
made up of other stuff
and in this case it's it's um
you know like previous volitions that
we've we've engaged in and
um
but but it retains this agency
because of the way it's put together um
so you know
epictetus will say that reason is a
system a network of appearances
at one point i think prior racist is
like that as well
there's clearly and this is something
that one of the other people um picked
out there's clearly
prior racists in the sense of like what
our prairie races ought to look like
like a perfect prior racist completely
in accordance with nature but that's
none of us that's that's the sage at
best who epictetus really doesn't talk
about at all
um and then there's the pro-races that
we have
you know
so i'm not i'm not that attracted to
this like i mean we could say there's
double senses of progresses
i'm cool with that
but i don't know that i want to say that
there's actually two prairie races or
two
personalities
yeah and i think that's what she
gets a bit uncertain himself from time
to time uh and he points out that well
in ordinary english we can talk in the
same way we can say something like i
hurt myself
that was reflexive language yeah yeah
that doesn't imply that there are two
selves and one is searching the other
yeah we have a whole bunch of reflexive
verbs in some languages use many more of
them you know like i wash myself you
know we we don't say that in english but
uh french you know just love right um
there's there's a whole bunch of
words that are there's a whole bunch of
verbs that don't make sense unless you
have the
you know
personal pronoun in there
yeah
or or the medium voice in greek so
exactly yeah yeah how am i i'm stopping
myself
yeah so yeah
uh shall we turn to the
third and fourth issue
um
so we got some more quotes here uh
inwood writes that uh
prohibitions in epictetus seems to be in
control of the other impulses and
faculties
and so is almost equivalent to the
hegemonical
long rights in the first discourse
is that that this is the one and only
faculty that the gods have placed in our
power what does it mean by this faculty
he glosses it in a number of ways it is
a reasoning faculty the only faculty
that we have that can have cognizance of
itself
it is our decelerative and impulsive
faculty
it is our capacity to give or withhold
ascent
it is our priorities our more character
it is the faculty that tells us whether
or not to do something that passes
judgment of the truth and value of
anything of which we have a
representation
a person's priorities is a function of
reason a state of the source commanding
part
um
do you want to say something great well
the read the next quote and then i i do
have something
yeah right now
yeah uh
the the previous quote was from historic
studies and this is from his monography
again uh
this congress could suggest that the
terms are synonymous synonymous in
epictetus i do not think this is right
although they overlap in the referent so
far as human beings are concerned
hegemonic on does not mean rationality
so this is a topic that that harald and
i have gone back and forth about with
him taking one position and me taking
another position and the positions are
not very far apart
the question is
should we identify
pro-erasus with
one with two other things the hegemony
cone the ruling faculty
or the rational part and my my point of
view
really until very recently and now i'm
more or less convinced of the point of
view harold has been articulating
is that um you've got the hegemony con
clearly important clearly a central part
of stoic anthropology
and you know pro-racists i was saying is
just the hegemony cone in a certain way
likewise the rational part is you know
a certain way and i think there's a lot
of places in epictetus where he uses
these pretty synonymously with each
other and where what he's saying about
the rational part applies you know about
its reflexivity applies to
uh the prior races or vice versa and so
these are just like different ways of
looking at things the rational part is
more about like our reasoning processes
and the prior races is more about choice
and practical reasoning and you know
that that sort of thing but they're all
the hegemony cone
and you know so like inward it seems
almost equivalent that almost is really
key there right long saying there's
overlap i think that's right
but
yeah maybe maybe the hegemony cone is
the broader
thing
and pro-racist should be seen as
a modality of it
yeah
uh i i think that is right and
i think i mentioned this earlier too
that uh
i i think that stories thought that
animals have a hegemonic on
yeah and they don't have a rational
hegemony code maybe maybe that's the key
part of the key difference you know
yeah
and i think that hegemonic is a bit more
i mean would the heck monochrome be the
thing that actually receives
uh
impressions without necessarily
uh rooting on them
um
well rules on some of them right
and it's it's affected by them as well
so
i mean
again going beyond our topic but if we
think about like the phenomenology of
perception to use mariluponte's title
and term
we're like taking in what the stoics
call fontasia all the time and we're
only attending to certain of them
um those that we think are
you know
particularly important and those those
are at the level of conscious perception
and then we do like decide what we're
going to do like if i taste my coffee
and suddenly there's a bug swimming
around in it and i take a sip and like
something's moving around in my mouth
i'm not paying attention to this this
you know this presentation anymore or
what's going on on the screen i'm paying
attention to what's going on in my mouth
and
i'm do i spit it out do i like you know
try to investigate further in a very
calm manner you know these are all
possibilities for my hagamonico
yeah
uh how are we doing on time now by the
way uh well we're we're getting close to
the end but um i i don't know if we'll
get at anything
we won't get to everything that we would
plan but let's let's keep going with
this because this is a really important
thing maybe we'll skip over the other
key distinctions
you know let's talk about the free will
stuff
free will stuff all right
uh
so that's your section what epictetus uh
modulo how privacy's determines
uh
well we've got three three passages here
that i think are
kind of interesting
um so stephen strange in stoicism
transitions traditions and
transformations says augustine even if
he does not create the modern notion of
the will is a much less remote ancestor
of it than the stoics which which
implies that the stoics and epictetus
are doing something different than what
we nowadays say freitas says something
very different freda says we have here
here we have our first actual notion of
a free will but it's a notion such that
not all human beings in fact have a free
will they're meant by nature to have a
free will that is each human being is
capable of having a free will and this
is what he says about epictetus
and then uh
chris gill uh describing khan in his uh
book the structure itself khan has this
this entire article where he's tracing
you know the development of free will
from like homer all the way to augustine
khan finds an epictetus a crucial stage
in the discovery of the will a process
he traces from aristotle to augustine
finally thomas aquinas the main point is
the idea of a highly unified locus
of motivation and action
in the stoic psychology this is
standardly seen as based on the unified
control center the hegemony con in the
stoicism of the late roman republic and
early empire
khan finds the emergence of a new
vocabulary
for expressing the integrated conception
of motivation in the use of voluntars
and seneca and prior races and epictetus
i'm kind of attracted to that view you
know i think that
pro-racist and epictetus isn't exactly
what augustine means by volontas
um
and it's not you know like the whole
large conception of the will that we
have maybe in the present but it's
pretty close you know and and i like
this this language of discovering the
will
the human being discovering something
that's been there all along and just was
not particularly well articulated it's
not like you know
if if we're aristotle we don't actually
have a will
we're just not able to articulate it as
well you know
yeah
so maybe we should jump down to talking
about
some of the ways in which
you know making good on our original
promise how does prior racist determine
itself
so
there's a couple things to say about
this in a lot of cases prior races is
going to be determined by things that
are not parieta racist there's a
receptivity in it to what's outside of
it by its very nature and some of these
are
uses of pro-irasis what we can call
pro-ra proretic decisions or
determinations of others you think about
your family and growing up in a certain
way the choices that your family members
make you know even about like decor
or you know when you wake up in the
morning or when you eat or when you have
to go to bed
education you know if teachers do indeed
shape us they're doing it by how they
use their prior races the workplace
political and social life a lot of these
are probably not directly aimed at
producing
you know things in our prior races
um they're just it just happens to do
that but you know we get messages we
learn things
pray racist is also reflexive
and here we get to the root prorace is
determines itself or necessitates or
compels itself
but the question we can say then is well
how does this happen
it's not like a magical process where it
just you know has a feedback loop
circling into itself
um and i think it would be wrong to
imagine it like a little homunculus
inside of ourselves who's perfectly
conscious and you know that's that's an
a nice imagination but that's not what
epictetus says and it's not remotely
like what we experience we when we make
choices about ourselves very often we do
so in in a consciousness of having made
the wrong choices in the past and trying
to fix ourselves in the present and
we're in this like fog or you know
limited horizon of well how do i unscrew
myself up in in the present
and here again you know epictetus tells
us reason is a systema of appearances i
think we should think of the prior races
as something complicated like a system
that chooses that we don't have full
consciousness of
and it chooses in particular
situations and moments and determines
itself
in in you know for larger contexts and
it's sometimes you know we sometimes do
this in terms of thinking about very
general things what kind of person do i
want to be
but most of the time like you know
harold has mentioned role ethics several
times in here i think a lot of the time
we're actually thinking well what do i
do within the context of this
relationship and the responsibilities
that i
i have
so
harl do you want to weigh in on some of
the more determinate ways in which
prairie races compels or determines
itself
well uh this ties
pretty nicely nicely into the next
section and i thought to bring about the
discussion on family affection
oh yeah yeah where there's a father who
had a sick daughter yeah which he ran
away from and then
uh
epictetus asked him to defend himself
because that seems like a really crappy
thing to do and then he says well it's
natural
and then they go into a socratic
dialogue um
on
well what doesn't really mean that
something is natural and yeah
here we see that uh epic it is not
committing the
naturalistic fallacy which we talk about
now in more modern philosophy it doesn't
say that well because something is
common then it's okay it's rather
natural it's more like an ideal
idealized conception of what the father
ought to do uh so a father wouldn't run
away from
from
his sick daughter
and
and that's this way in which projects
governs itself you can sort of
bring out an idea and try to
follow that idea and to see what you
ought to do in a certain situation
that's that's and that actually brings
out something that's implicit in
epictetus's practice but he doesn't
thematize that much which is
we don't modify our proraces just by
retreating to the inner citadel you know
and actually epictetus says by the way
your your inner citadel it's a citadel
of vices you gotta destroy those because
they've built up citadels inside you
before you're going to be able to do
anything
um
but you don't you don't just like
retreat within and then like you know
think to yourself in a kind of like
cartesian way you do so in relation to
others and the best part about others is
sometimes they can say hey man you're
screwing up you know you need to fix
this
yeah like this is doing with that guy
yeah and another interesting uh idea
that he has is that well you can't
really maintain your own uh
relationships unless you focus on
the good on
prohibitions yeah that's right
and that's really interesting idea
so yeah
um
and a few other ways uh if i may uh in
how
epic is things that we can govern uh
viruses is that we
can bring about counter impressions uh
or reframe a few things so when he talks
about how we can find uh solitude
challenging uh well let me stress that
you try to reframe it as peace mind
peace and quiet
and if you're bothered by the crowds
then you try to
think about the crowd as a festival
so yeah those are great examples yeah
yeah
uh and uh i also think that if you have
a
problem with um
a particular advice like lust for
instance um
then you can try to bring counter
impression to that you know uh
so instead of imagining how it is to
have sex with with a certain person that
you're not supposed to have sex with you
can try to
uh imagine how it would be to be
the kind of person who can
withstand that kind of temptation
that's a great way to unpack that line
that he has you know when you encounter
a beautiful girl or boy well you just
turn to temperance and you're like well
how do you do that you know
so
so uh it it you know it almost sounds
like you're saying oh you got temperance
inside you just bring it up you know
just bringing it up means having to
deliberately especially at the beginning
we have to like deliberately
do
exercises
and this leads us you know into a larger
topic of of what ado calls you know
spiritual exercises
um i think his his work is quite helpful
in that respect but what he's doing is
he's just bringing to light stuff that's
that's already there in the texts
um
yeah
i mean another thing too there's there's
another cognitive means because
reframing is cognitive
all the places where epictetus says
remember this or have ready at hand
there's a dogma that you're supposed to
have like thought through and made part
of your repertoire
and so when you get into a situation
where you're prior racist which is not
perfect is tempted to move in this
direction
like with anger you can remind yourself
he's got this you know really great
uh analogy about you know you've allowed
yourself to be scourged and you've got
scars what you're gonna like whip
yourself some more and like raise you
know things on top of the scars and this
is a bodily metaphor
but it you know you can apply it and
think oh yeah i'm really destroying
myself by allowing myself to lose my
temper in this this case
and that's that's how pro-racist works
upon itself you know
yeah
so it's very practical as well it's
theoretical
yeah
um
there's you know there's another thing
that i think we could talk about
um attentiveness so
you know sometimes this gets translated
as mindfulness and and actually in the
the recently uh published um stoicism
today volume three there's a great essay
in there
by greg lopez saying that um
stoic prosoke
um maybe isn't the same thing as
buddhist mindfulness actually he's he's
not saying maybe it isn't he's saying
totally not the same thing and here's
the here's the textual evidence why
um
but
attentiveness is itself quite important
and that's something that we can direct
using
our faculty of choice i can
be attentive or be
thoughtless you know i can choose to
extend my attentiveness as people do in
mindfulness practices
and i can also like choose not to look
at things that i should if i know that i
have an anger problem and somebody
points out to me hey you're getting
angry
if i choose not to listen to them
you know and take advantage of their
better perspective
right i'm i'm that's my prior racist i'm
responsible for that
so
yeah i think that it was either long or
throughout she you made a point that
viruses is a bit more
wider than it is for aristotle in this
regard since uh it's not simply a
commitment about uh becoming an athlete
or something it's rather
something that goes on all the time uh
and perhaps attention ties into that too
that he tries to be a bit attentive to
the inner monologue in your head it is
interesting though that in aristotle he
doesn't use the word prayer racist there
but it's coming up in the context of
whether we're responsible for our
characters
he talks about um
maybe somebody could be excused and and
you say oh they're just not a person who
pays attention to things and then
aristotle says well
they've allowed themselves to become
that kind of person which
does seem prioritic doesn't it
it does
yeah well that's a good point
yeah i think in aristotle prior racist
is just so underdetermined and
mixed up that um
in some respects either
if we can come up with a coherent
picture of epictetune proarases there
isn't an equally coherent aristotelian
picture of it to compare side by side
you
know yeah
uh we're going on for about an hour now
uh should we perhaps yeah for questions
yeah we should probably wrap up so you
know long story short you know take care
of your priorities it's an important
thing
so that's about it
thank you
i think you're muted all though
and if thanks i took a lot of notes let
me see first the questions from the chat
uh
from danilo patucci
no no not there's one
here
oh uh there there was a question there
about what is the article so it's it's
it's uh you can find it in the blog
stoicism today and also in the recently
published book
um it's greg lopez l-o-p-e-z
and i i don't remember the exact title
off hand but it's about
about stoic mindfulness
might be mindfulness and buddhism and
stoicism but it's easy enough to find
just google lopez gregory stoic
mindfulness you should be able to find
it pretty quickly
and he he has also another question yeah
oh
yeah this is a good one for harold
because he he doesn't see the relation
between prohibited and idols in epithets
yeah uh
tony long has written a bit about it i
think the there's a subchapter in his
monologue or his monograph on epictetus
so that's a good place to start um but i
think that there is a connection um if
paris deals in with how we habituate uh
and how we
not simply
uh habits in the
more common sense but also uh mental
habits thinking habits then uh it seems
like
uh idols or a sense of shame or
integrity as uh tony long translators um
tie into it we can
use cyber viruses in a messed up way and
break down our sense of shame and then
it will become easier for us to
commit shameful acts
yeah you know
there's also the tendency
because people feel shame
to not attend to what they ought to
attend to right
so this is this is when people make
apologies that aren't real apologies
um they say oh i'm sorry that i i made
you feel a certain way you know or i'm
sorry that you feel that way right and
the reason why people say stuff like
that is because they're unwilling to
take genuine responsibility
and why would they feel that way i mean
they could feel that way because they're
just you know hopeless narcissists
who think that they never do anything
wrong but i think a lot of people do it
out of a sense of
shame and and every time that you're
feeling shame it's it's like it presents
you with you know different paths that
you could take in the prayer races is is
what's choosing those paths for you do
you
do you try to avoid you know talking
about the situation well that's your
priorisis deciding that or do you
do the difficult and painful you know
work of saying oh yeah i really screwed
up it was me who screwed up
can i do anything to make this up for
you are you going to be mad at me for a
long time you know i guess i have to
take that you know i can't demand uh
forgiveness from you that's that's
another way of using a and this actually
this is another um thing that we didn't
talk about epictetus
um one of the key things that prayer
racist does is what's in greek crisis
which we translate as dealing with
or
um
using you know and everything that that
happens to us all the appearances all
the situations
we can
deal with them or use them in in certain
ways and that's that's up to us even the
things that are external epictetus says
they are external and indifferent but
insofar as we can use them they're not
external and indifferent they are up to
us and they are a matter of the prairie
races
so shame is yeah shame is really
important
and it's got a bad rap like like yeah
there's a lot of cases where it's a good
thing to feel ashamed right
yeah it is and at least in norway these
days we talk about um
being shameless almost like a virtue
and yeah
i mean
not feeling shame about having a
rumbling stomach during a lecture or
something that's probably a good thing
but yeah
being able to steal or treat to rape in
worst case i mean
you ought to feel shame if you do any of
those things
aristotle has a very interesting
discussion because he doesn't want to
consider shame to be a virtue
this is a nick of mccain ethics book for
um although he does consider it to be a
middle state
and he says that a good person won't
actually feel shame but were they to do
something that was that was wrong like
steal somebody's stuff right um steal
somebody's textbook in in a class steal
from your classmate
then they would feel shame
so it's it's like counterfactual
you know whereas the shameless person
will just do whatever they want to and
that's not a good thing it's it's it's a
bad thing you know
yeah i was talking if uh daniel about it
and he he presents the passage of aries
where he talked where haris talks about
these
virtues which are not knowledge
and i talked to that maybe we could put
idos here because it's not no it's not a
virtue because virtue is knowledge for
st for the strikes yeah yeah but there
are some virtues
that all virtue no sorry all knowledge
is virtual but not all virtue is
knowledge
uh some virtues that depends uh of uh
what's the word uh daniel
of uh
asked right of practicing them right
right and we can say that there's
components right so so
knowledge is a i think it's better to
think of it knowledge
a virtue isn't itself just knowledge
it's knowledge plus right
yeah
and uh i i have a lot of
points here um first the point you
who mentioned at the end of your
presentation
uh about prohibited
is and the hegemony cone
because usually in
the speciesism rehearsing is divided
into seven parts from the senses
reproducing capacity voice and
is
the eighth part of
the soul
as something like the hegemony con
being
aware of itself
because you can say that the
in
hegemonic
sense automatically
it it produces
presentations all the time about
internal things but
we is totally up to us we can somehow
stop the process and update the the
the
opinions you have labeled or you have
used in our thought i have used in i
mean
i i think that a lot of the times the
pro-iracists is working
less
um deliberatively less consciously in
epictetus because there's all these
passages where he says where he like
connects um reasoning processes and he
says hey don't get angry at people
because they've got you know these these
uh wrong assumptions and then they
reason from them
and that happens in kind of an implicit
or automatic way of practical reasoning
and then you know he likens that to you
know the same thing is going on with
with like badly formed desires or
aversions
um and habits and stuff like that
so i do think that there is a
part and i i i do think that that both
the rational faculty and the prior
racist they kind of interfuse each other
and they're part of the hagamonicon
um i think that a good bit of the time
what's happening is unconscious even for
those of us who've made progress
you know but you're right there is also
this whatever we want to call it and it
gets difficult to we use this word
reflexivity where it can apply to itself
but you know existentialists use words
like lucidity you know like camus is
always talking in that framework and
that's not a bad way like a light you
know a sort of illumination of holy crap
this is me you know
for better for worse
i think that's important too that
self-consciousness
um
and that happens both in terms of like
our
moral awareness you could say in which
the pro-racists you could think of is
that way and also in terms of our just
like rationality
right
as harrah's pointed out
prohibits not free in literal sense but
something we can make free right yeah
yeah
it's not free it if it works but it's it
is in a bad state right
yeah and it's not as if it's like
free and content-less the way that
people often like frame the will and in
free-will discussions right
it's it's already like
got all these complex habits built up
and
and you know things impinging on it and
we have like this little sliver of
freedom whatever we want to call it this
capacity to like go this way rather than
this way or to like pay attention to
ourselves and try to be less less bad
than we are you know and and the more
that we do that gradually maybe it goes
from being a little tiny sliver to being
i don't know one-fifth of ourselves
[Music]
but it's never like the totality of who
we are it's not like we're
angels in the you know
uh yeah
sense where we have like perfect
knowledge and
you know
yeah there's some light uh on the
subject of prohibitis
and hexes and
atus right but usually i i think about
providers in an epistemic way uh
concerning the opinions and that you can
manage this talk of opinions from which
the prohibitors take its decisions so uh
can we make prohibitive how can we make
prohibitions free by scrutinizing these
opinions and which holds their center to
the false ones
how how do you think about this process
yeah
i think it's the the uh
epithetian
mode to apply the socratic methods right
yeah analyzing our own opinions about
the world
you know and as i was rereading uh some
some of the long stuff
to prepare for this
in in his epictetus book
um
long actually suggests that um we should
look at epictetus as a socratic
yeah you know i i like that suggestion
and i think that epictetus uh thinks
thinks about himself as a socratic too
to a very large extent
um so we we can seek say
analyzing our presentations is
is
similar to what soccer did
discussing uh
essential
ideas with his friends and so on
it's the eptn version of it right
yeah
it's and it's a it's a linguistic
process right even if you're doing it in
your own head dialectic is still
yeah you're having a conversation with
yourself testing presentations in
less analysis is testing
beliefs about reality yeah
about what we are what about the
external world and so on
i mean you brought up this as being an
epistemic process but i kind of think
that what we see in these robust virtue
ethics whether it's platonist or
aristotelian or or stoic or you know
later christian stuff is the
intersection of epistemological and
moral
motifs you know there's there's many
ways it's interesting because there's
this whole field that developed an
analytic philosophy where they totally
reinvented wheels called virtue
epistemology right and when it came out
those of us who are doing history of
philosophy were like well this is not
something new this has actually been
done
through ancient philosophy
the entire critical thinking movement is
kind of doing this before you guys came
to it
i actually wrote a paper a while back
about how phenomenology you know people
like shayler and fond hildenbrand and
mark marcel were already attuned to this
but it is good that that analytic
philosophers came to realize that um
epistemology and moral philosophy do
intersect with each other you know
um
there's so many ways in which we can't
know things adequately oh you know i
mean we can know things like we can go
on wikipedia and look things up but we
don't know what to do with that
information unless we've had some sort
of moral formation
and we don't even even necessarily have
to be good you know this thing about
shame if we are motivated by
an understanding of how badly off we are
in relation to where we ought to be
that that can tell us something
epistemologically we could learn to well
maybe i shouldn't trust
the things that
people are telling me right um
or i should uh only only listen to
certain uh sources um
[Music]
yeah that's nasty that's a great thing
too so like going back to the thing
about is is virtue just knowledge
if virtue was just knowledge then we
wouldn't need escasis
exactly exactly exactly that's the whole
point yeah
but uh i mean
i i think that the stoics had a more
uh restrictive sense of knowledge than
what we do um
i i think that they would say that well
if i
steal a bar of chocolate from the store
then i don't really know that that is
wrong uh i can say that i
i might know that it's against law or
something like that but knowledge seems
to be something a bit deeper it's about
internalizing a set of
notions rather than simply having a
passive sense that for instance uh
new york is on the eastern coast united
states uh yeah
yeah we could talk about different modes
of knowledge right and this is getting
us uh going out of the stoic perspective
this is one of the big problems in
plato's texts that i think later
neoplatonists managed to deal with
better even middle plateaus like
plutarch with plato the bar for what
counts as knowledge is very very high
and
everything gets thrown into the same
basket you know yeah and he often uses
techne and epistemize if they're
basically synonyms with each other
so you know medicine is a knowledge
rhetoric is a knowledge or maybe not
maybe it's just a knack you know but
maybe if it's the good rhetoric and when
we get to aristotle we see
it's not a perfect um account but at
least there's an attentiveness to
different modalities of knowledge so
phronesis is something quite different
than techne
or episteme you know um
i think that's that's that's quite
important and then you know we see
further refinements of this as we get
further
along
there's another note of that
just think loud and then her choices
implies
the choice
in our values as persons
you know integrity or lack of
integrity the values we have to do to
ourselves by action of idols as
moral
yeah that's a good good and complicated
question
[Laughter]
yeah
i mean this is actually okay this is a
very interesting topic um yeah there are
there are times when
we can have almost like this double
consciousness
where
we're not ashamed about something and
we're like i should probably feel
ashamed about this
and so we feel almost like on a higher
level
a sense that it's not yet shame it's a
sense something is wrong because we're
not feeling shame and then we say how am
i far gone am i too far gone to improve
myself you know am i shameless
right um and in some of the cases it
might be like what harold was talking
about like your stomach rumbling if you
so for instance i had a mother and and
never she never really got to to stick
with me she did not like people to spit
on the ground and it was a very
irrational
thing i don't know where it came from
for her but she would see people like
across the street doing it and she would
like make you know mean faces
she told us we should never do it and i
i never saw it as that that big of a
deal that's clearly the kind of thing
that we we probably shouldn't feel shame
about and if we do it's because we've
been we've had ideas imposed upon us
right
um
you know
passing wind
people get very ashamed about that to
the extent that they hold it into the
detriment of their health
um benjamin franklin back in in the days
actually wrote a book about this called
fart proudly you know um
so there's there's some things that we
probably you know need to
feel less shame about now i i think if
potatoes
has in mind that kind of shame if you
feel sometimes you know
there are so shameful things we do that
even years later they remember it and
feel shame and sometimes you you feel
shame about the order you see the order
doing
uh such a shameful fact that we feel it
as we did we have
ourselves it's very
when i was a kid and and i would watch
uh situation comedies on on television
uh and may i think there's a lot of
other people who have this experience
you know they're set up to have uh goofy
situations happen and somebody does
something embarrassing and then you feel
almost a um what would you call it a a
sympathetic sort of shame for them
for me that was so strong that sometimes
i had to leave the room and not watch
the show because i
cringing i think cringe being feeling
something cringey is is it's it's more
centered on the other person there's
less of a
there's less of i feel this for you
in aspect
um
i mean the the the concept of cringe is
is one that
probably could use a a significant
analysis right we're still inventing our
moral vocabulary
as time goes on is there is there a
portuguese
uh like cognate or
um
or similar term to what in english we
call cringe
i don't know i never never seen these
words before let's ask
he's also an english teacher yeah what
do you think about
i think you're muted still
yeah
let me see in the in the dictionary
well i i i don't know if you have
another uh
good
word for that but let me take this
opportunity
to say something
although maybe
uh we found some good link between um
galen and attitus
yeah
i was talking about this is very
interesting because
we have been talking about uh pro high
energies in galen
i've been working on
gayness php
and
ad is it shows up 23 times
in ph php
but i i got some very important
information from you guys that i i was
not aware of
uh
if it proved hiatus is not uh in the
store
let's say xeno
uh
uh diogenes chrysopos
but it is very strong it is very strong
yeah
and prohibited is very important for
galen
and and uh he is using prohibited to
determine
the location of the hegemony call
so
at this point i don't know if
this is the hegemony core itself or is
some part of the hegemony call or some
function of the hegemony call
yeah uh yeah i'm not sure about that yet
lace lacy translates prohibited
as choice
most of the time or volition which is
yeah which would be the same thing and
sometimes when it comes with kinesis
it's like a voluntary action
which is actually by choice i guess yeah
so um and uh it is
but
when you
you guys have told us
that this is not the store i went to
check the php
and it is it is interesting because
the quotes that php has from christopher
xeno diogenes yes prohibited does not
show up there
so it is it is something that it is in
galen and we know that again have
written a book about the titus yeah yeah
but we don't know
what what this book is about and we have
been looking for a link and maybe for
the first time we have a very strong
link now it's very
very interesting you know i mean this is
a place where we're so handicapped
by
the like total loss of the early stoic
literature and and the middle stoic
literature too because i mean if there's
anybody where we would have expected to
see some comparative analysis of it
would be posidonius you know
um but you know we we have these book
titles and
we don't we don't know um what's in
these very interesting books unless we
have glosses
you know often
i mean galen is not a hostile
witness the way plutarch is you know um
but he's not a
totally sympathetic
witness either right yeah yeah he has
some problems
yeah
i mean it is interesting too you know as
we mentioned um
so
marcus aurelius really likes epictetus
and brings him up all the time
prior races is not a concept from
epictetus that marcus seems very
interested in and galen and marcus
there's a connection there you know yeah
so
yeah it's hard to know what to make of
this stuff i mean harold do you have any
ideas about
no not really um
but it might be that
the other stoic thought that uh they
could talk about the same thing with
more established um
established concepts like hierarchies or
classes or something like that
yeah
but then
then again uh the problem is why did the
epictetus field need to pick up viruses
uh yeah what what was the question
yeah i mean inwood talks about this in
in his book on early stoicism and and he
says that
his take is that the um
the stoics want to produce their own
vocabulary
that is going to take up some of the
same space that the aristotelians and
and platonists and others are are using
and so if the aristotelians are using
prairie races the stoics are not going
to use it they're going to use other
things instead and focus like on ascent
you know um and that kind of makes sense
to me
um
where it's it's it's a uh it's not like
a deliberative they all got together in
committee and decided okay
resolved we will not use the term
progresses
um
yeah and it's all
always the problem of
insufficient uh sources i mean if you
have access to all the stuff that happy
kitty spread as he was living then maybe
it would have been obvious why went for
that term rather than
one of the others yeah
i mean and
the only reference that we have in
epictetus's existing discourses to
aristotelians is not a um
it's not an endorsement of them it's
their well they're like epic they're
they're like epicureans with a little
bit more consistency or something like
that it's not there's something to
emulate
yeah we're talking about the the uh at
the start of what do you think uh that
do you think that vp took for hires from
aristotle as
anthony long
proposes or
he's in fact answering some uh
peripathetic attacks and using the
body patex words to answer it as dubbing
dubbing
and then transforming the concept right
dubbing who translated the part of the
that we put here i don't know how to
pronounce it i mean it's not just
aristotle who uses it
it is being used by other
um
other people
who aren't stoics you know like i
mentioned you know plutarch i mean
epictetus isn't getting it from plutarch
obviously but it's showing up there
um
and so maybe that maybe there's like a
current not so much of aristotle but a
broader current of use of the term
again you know if we had posidonius as
works you know
um maybe
maybe we'd find you know connections
there because he engages uh plato and
aristotle deliberately
um
and is willing to say wow you know they
got some things right that the stoics
didn't get right
um
i don't know or maybe if we had more of
musonius rufus's stuff
maybe he talked about it but we we don't
know we only have those you know handful
of lectures and then a few fragments
yeah
that's a real mystery
yeah yeah i mean we can hope that you
know
uh as more of the materials that hercule
and am come about uh that maybe we find
some stoic stuff in there but it seems
seemed the prospect seemed pretty
unlikely yeah maybe from
your library
yeah
they will read some of those of those
couple nights and quarters
right
yeah
danilo said that we don't have a synonym
usually we say that
we feel the shame of the order we use a
an expression
yeah
we actually say cringe in norwegian too
so it's just becoming a uh a loanword
yeah yeah
and how do you think about
how
putting the products in a good state
because the pichito
he says that
we are our own opinions
and other times he says that we are our
prohibitions so we establish a link
between
our beliefs and our prohibitions
how can you put
the progress in a good state from this
point of view i mean part of it is
figuring out which of our beliefs are
false or
alienating us from other people or
getting in the way of our performing our
duties and there's usually a lot of
those once we start looking into it
and it's very much you know with moral
improvement it's very much like peeling
an onion right we start out we we start
reading the stoics or aristotle or
whoever we're like oh this is really
great i can i can start working on this
this one little bit of myself that i
thought was you know not really great
because i'm otherwise really great and
we start digging into it and it turns
out oh no it's a bigger problem than i
thought you know and it becomes a
lifelong process
you know and
over time we come to realize just how
badly off we actually are and
how our how our parents kind of screwed
us up and education you know there's all
these these things to it right
but but i think you know the the
needs are really central to that right
um
so so maybe we have we have a
requirement
you know and so in a certain respect a
cart is kind of exemplary in this i want
to actually take some time in a stove
heated room now that i've i've got some
leisure to like think through all the
all the various bs that i've accumulated
and you know think to be true that's not
a bad idea you know
maybe the treating it all is false
you know that's a problem but you could
also see that as a deliberate effort to
break the hold that those things have on
us you know
descartes is influenced by the stoics we
know that you know
what do you think harold
i think that is right and i think that's
in the uh text
as well i mean it does talk about uh
working our conceptions or um prolepsis
and uh especially about what is
beneficial i mean that's a big one uh
yeah yeah
another thing that's a prolapse a set of
prolapses
what is in our power and what's not
epictetus thinks that we're confused
about that to begin with um
and that you know we have to work on
that over time
um so it's not so simple as like you put
somebody you know you give them
encouraging uh one i think this is where
a lot of people doing modern stoicism
um sometimes go off the track they're
like uh oh dichotomy control that's all
i need man you know and all we got to do
is read uh you know the end caribbean
and maybe
uh
book one chapter one of of uh the
discourses and now i know everything i
need to know about it and and then they
get themselves into all sorts of trouble
um
because you know stoicism is a complex
system right so
yeah that's what i was about to say uh
uh in particular looks at first sight
very simple but it's very complex right
yeah yeah extremely complex it and it's
a problem
not only to understand it or understand
his philosophy but also to translate him
yeah a very complex philosophy yeah
and people think otherwise because they
read the man oh that's easy
yeah yeah
yeah so this is just a chicken soup for
the soul i mean i don't think that's
right at all
yeah
so well and actually those sort of
misunderstandings of stoicism i think
uh contain
ways of of going astray so and in ways
that like if epictetus were around today
he probably would have a similar
socratic discourse like the guy who
um claimed that he was motivated by
familial affection to leave his his
daughter so if epictetus were around
today he probably would be you know
calling on to the the proverbial mat
some people who have these very
simplistic takes and saying well
let's think this out you know what's
what's wrong with this you know
if you do retreat just inside of
yourself aren't you leaving other people
that you have responsibilities to
in the lurch you know if you're if
you're a parent
um
just
you know withdrawing from everything
that bothers you
or saying oh you're just an appearance
you know you don't really matter when
your your kid is getting bullied
that's a problem you know yeah
and that ties into a big question that
we didn't discuss but um whether
epictetus um
idea of the self is fundamentally
different from for instance here please
so here glade seems to have this idea
that you're supposed to extend the self
while it seems like epictetus is trying
to narrow it down to
the minimal
so
that's maybe a topic for another
another day
it would be interesting to discuss
tensions between
um the stoic figures that we we do have
rather because there's a tendency i
think for a lot of people to say well
they must all be basically thinking the
same thing let's see if we can you know
um systematize them all into to one vast
thing and i think ado is doing that you
know that's part of why i i don't buy
the
epic td in three discourses
three three um topoi being like the
hermeneutic to understanding the the
stoic system because it's it's pretty
late
um and then there's also a counter
tendency to like well there's the real
stoics and then there's seneca
who's not real stoic because he's a rich
guy and he he liked the epicureans you
know and i think what we actually need
is a much more nuanced
understanding that makes room for the
differences between the stoics and also
you know so bringing in galen bringing
in cicero bringing in plutarch these
people who are
not themselves
stoics but have a lot to tell us i mean
from cicero we learn so much that
otherwise would be would be lost to us
you know yeah like i guess gregory if
you try to draw online and story season
you're going to get into a big mess
it is not easy yeah
yeah
what would you propose instead of a line
like something like
continua or i don't know
yeah
yeah
it is a challenge and uh it seems like
uh in the beginning it was even wider so
we had someone like aristotle kiosks for
instance uh it was quite in disagreement
with uh zeno and chrysippus
yeah and zeno himself we could consider
to be sort of an eclectic right he
studies with representatives of three
different schools he's also modeling
himself after this socrates guy who has
influenced these
three different schools the cynic the
maguiri
didn't call himself a stoic at all
well that's right yeah that's right
yeah it was a socratic
yeah i think that by now we have a very
simplified picture of what was stoicism
in the past because we just started to
study all the material there there are a
lot of material a lot of text that
nobody
read
and
i think in
maybe in a hundred years you will have a
better picture yeah i'm not kidding i
think it
it's a lot of time to understand all
these and to yeah
i mean do you think that in a way
the phenomenon that we call modern
stoicism
is
creating more of this simplistic picture
because there's you know there's there's
people out there who want to
self-identify to the point where they're
they're bringing in all sorts of things
that are like total externals i'm gonna
get a stoic tattoo you know or or things
along those lines and it's very much
like a
i want to join a club and then you need
to have boundaries
um do you think the the modern stoic
phenomena is is uh
creating some problems in this way
maybe
but also the
simplified a lot with the picture
as you said he presents
he's a great researcher and i'm not
putting it in doubt but
he his view about spaces is too
simplistic right and yeah and
many people took it as
he put it and
i think it
does not
help us to
understand more to
to go deeper in the studies of stoicism
yeah my problem is my question is how
can you make it simple
if it is something so complex
that's my question and the second point
is that uh
when you try to do that it is there is a
good chance you are going to ignore the
physics and the logic of the system
that's the point
yeah
or there's there's that you can say
there's a correlative thing because what
we have of the logic and and even more
the physics is rather you know
fragmentary
or it's you know we're like very
indebted to cicero like you know if we
think about the what's the stoic
theology well a lot of it we get from on
the nature of the gods and that mitre
might not be accurate you know
i think a lot of people
um who get into that and say oh we we
have to have
we have which is i think you're
completely right it has to be integrated
right yeah then they they it's almost
like they're they're sort of like
fundamentalists with the bible they do a
lot of proof texting from the little
passages that we have rather than a more
um
attentive and thoughtful let's let's put
these things together and and we're
relying on a testimony rather than a
direct
passage we have to be a bit careful you
know
yeah that's the point i think that
stoicism
today
he is mass kilter
creature of mass
and
as a religion also
and
not rely anymore on the books as
lotte dyke says in his paper about the
new pack of
new human pack i don't know if you read
it
he says that uh the the old cuter of
learning through books is dying and now
the most modern
ways of communication are killing the
uncertain
ways of of thinking and everything and
historicism
as
religion as everything else
is going through these postmodern
ways of communication and he is at the
same time being
diminished
he's being adapted to
run through jesus
i'm i'm very skeptical of trying to make
stoicism into a substitute for religion
for people who have abandoned whatever
religious
you know
background that they
they had to satisfy some some urges
because i mean what we know is stoic
religion is there isn't any real prayer
i mean we have the prayer you know to
zeus but it's basically hey let you know
let things just go the way they they go
epictetus says don't go to divination
um or if you do only for things where
you've like exhausted every other
resource so so what would a stoic
religion
really look like i mean you can talk
about religiosity yeah i guess gregory
do you think that they strike religions
more physics than
anything
well that's where we would find focus
yeah
because the cosmology is all yeah
exactly
you know in ancient in ancient physics
also like so aristotle's on the soul is
considered a physical text right so
the stuff that we're learning
um about
how the body and the mind you know
really the same thing interact because
it's all you know substance and pneuma
for the stoics
they're materialists
you know that's that's physics
right
i guess you could actually consider
seneca's letters of consolation where he
gets uh he's got the stuff about the
astro uh maybe he's a good guy he'll
live in the stars that's physics too
right yeah
yeah
but this co they cosmology the religion
the cosmology
[Music]
from the store is very beautiful it's
very
yeah and so you can have a an attitude
towards it of
like awe or
um you know a reception of of beauty or
something like that
and that i think if you want to if
that's what you mean by religion then i
don't see any problem with that it's
when it turns into like talismans and
you know um
almost like superstition right carrying
around a stoic challenge coin
you know helps me with my memento mori
or something like that that strikes me
as like no different than
somebody you know with a wwjd bracelet
or you know
yeah another another issue we have uh
today is that who is trying to do that
make the
store a very nice religion expression
yeah uh
it has some problems to get rid of the
the the influence from the christianism
so it kind of mix everything and and
then it is not stolen anymore yeah i've
even seen somebody put out something
they call the stoic bravery and i think
i think a bravery is a great thing you
know because if you want to learn about
uh christian monasticism
one of the best ways to do it besides
reading the the monks is to pray the
liturgy of the hours and see what that's
like right but i don't think that's the
way most people treat a brevary they
they treat it almost something more like
a rosary you know this repetitive thing
that you do and
which
you know can be good for some people but
does very often look much more like
superstition than religion
you know i agree yeah
in my view that there is a spirituality
in socialism but not
as a religion but something yeah similar
to
to i
always think about carl sagan okay
he's the way he's he he sees the cosmos
and he says that he's beautiful and and
so you must study physics because
through it you you know cosmos you know
the true beauty something about it and
if
you see for instance seneca he wrote a
whole book about physics and
in it he says that his most important
part of philosophy yeah and so i think
the strikes
gave a lot of value to to perceiving the
beauty of the universe through the study
of what what they they called their
physics
right yeah and i think that that is one
of the cause from chris that has
actually uh been transmitted all the way
down to us now that uh i think he said
something like well there is uh nobody
pay no better place to start to learn
about ethics than contemplating the
costs or
something to that effect so i i think
that the stories thought that connection
between physics and
ethics was uh very tight
so let me ask let me throw a question
out there you know we live in a very
different cosmol
different
universe cosmologically than than what
the ancients had do do we still have the
same
does it still have the same resource
for us of you know providing us with
beauty
you know we don't have a
um
nice orderly structured heavens or
anything with spheres
um let alone with you know beautiful
music or stuff like that but we do have
you know it's pretty cool to like
learn about what's what's out there you
know
what the picture we have is much faster
um
i think for some people it's scary right
they're like wow we're this tiny
insignificant thing now we actually know
how how deeply insignificant we are
um but i mean you could have that back
in ancient times i think it just wasn't
quite as big
so i don't know does does
thinking about things let's say we were
to take a stoic physics
a you know a modified one uh attitude
towards things does that um does it have
the same
capacity to move us in the present
uh i think that one important thing is
that
you can explain the cosmos with math and
i think that's one of the key ideas for
the source is that the cosmos is
rational in a sense yeah yeah when you
do
when you are able to explain the cosmos
by math and by a handful of physical
constants then
i i think that the state still would
claim that uh the university is
rational yes
yeah but well maybe we lost the
connection compared with the store
experience i think we lost the
connection and maybe by you know
simple things like we live in big cities
today yeah yeah
with
so many lights and we don't see the sky
anymore yeah for example
so
we don't have that kind of
relationship with the cosmos anymore
if we live in a big city we go to the
planetarium
yeah exactly
there's a program that like okay now
we're looking at this
yeah
yeah and i think the first experience
comes from this contemplation yeah
you know that that's what moves people
to thinking about the cosmos is the you
you see yourself
facing something that is so amazing and
then but we don't have that experience
today
yeah the story sky above me and the
moral law within me yeah
yeah
yeah that's right he didn't have to go
very far i mean kunisberg must have had
some light pollution but he could just
like walk outside the city limits and
and open himself up to that
yeah
i i this is what called my attention at
first in story season because
it put
me again in relation to nature
in our culture we are totally humans and
nature are totally separate
in many many aspects and stoicism put us
together again
although nature keeps breaking its way
back in you know like the the emblem of
the the grass breaking through the
concrete is is a good one you know
um then you can keep like killing it
with pesticide or painting over it or
laying more concrete but it's it's it
still
resists us uh
it's not the same thing as like a full
it's not it's not like going out into a
an actual nature preserve and getting to
experience what it's like to be in a
place that doesn't have any concrete
um
but it does it does afford us
opportunities i mean we're really
fortunate here in milwaukee
uh the city that i live in because
milwaukee had a significant influence
from the germans who fled the
revolutions after they failed in 1848
and so one of the things that they felt
was that poor people should have access
to green space to parks and so
we have
per you know for the size of our city we
have many more parks than many other
cities and it's and it's something
that's part of our
our way of life compared to say our
larger sister city to the south chicago
where there are you know there's parks
but just not as much
and it does affect a person's way of
life but and this goes to you know back
to that question that aldo had about
beliefs and the prior races it requires
a certain kind of attentiveness because
it's really easy to walk down the street
and not pay attention to anything around
you
or to be a kid who's like on their on
their phone all the time and not
looking at at you know the stuff when
they're being taken to the park
yeah a friend of mine likes to say that
we will never destroy nature
nature will destroy us
we have been trying to do that for
centuries i mean we we might be trying
to kill the rats the issue
if you're thinking about new york they
have more rat than human beings
right mosquitoes yeah uh
cockroach everything they still live in
and we and you know as you said you see
the
the
the the little
uh seed blooming through the concrete
it's it's amazing yeah
and i don't think we've been able to
kill metaphysics either so yeah that's
intense that's good
there's actually an article by jean-luc
marion that came out like in the 90s
called the end of the end of metaphysics
yeah that's something i heard sometimes
that people say oh stoicism too old
how can you do before today but i say
but christianism is also very old and
people follow
anyway
there's no problem right
yeah yeah
an idea doesn't become any truer
uh by being neither old nor new i mean
that's
actually irrelevant
yeah
exactly yeah
it does not survive for for no reason
right yeah
[Laughter]
hey guys uh i think it was an excellent
talk
yeah we appreciate your
presentation
and
i'm really happy
about it
thank you it was great to be here
yeah that's awesome i hope it's
sometimes working sometime we can have a
draft together i don't know if you drink
but
more orange juice i don't know
i prefer a draft of beer but
yeah
that'd be great
and
something else to say well thank you
gregory in herald very very nice
uh
contribution
it was really important for me because i
going i'm going through some research on
exactly the high energies and that's
that was so nice to
to hear all the information that uh
you guys brought to us thank you very
much oh thank you
in the chat the the link to modern
statism
which
greg and harold
are the editors right and
so you have some message to the
brazilians
it's a good accent
thank you
okay and if
if you want to
we will make a dossier of this uh
this symposium this seminar and if you
want to send us some text to translate
it to the portuguese
please you are welcome
well thanks very much thank you all
right okay i think the brazilians must
know more about your your excellent job
yes
yeah
we can translate yeah that's nice
and thank you for having us this was a
great experience yes all right thank you
many thanks and
and too soon
we'll see you later see ya see you later
bye bye
you